the last of their kind
but to energy the only female Northern
white rhinos in the world are under
Round the Clock surveillance in this
Century in central Kenya
Sudan the last male died in 2018.
when these animals came to this country
it was envisaged that they would breed
naturally now close to 10 years really
we began then thinking of what is the
best artificial means of recovering
these species
scientists are using IVF in vitro
fertilization of procedure that's never
been tried before with Wildlife using
preserved sperm from diseased bowls and
eggs harvested artificially from Fatu
and Nagin they've created pure Northern
White Rhino embryos it's a process that
is has not been simple because it being
novel it means every stage of the way
has to be proven has to be reviewed has
to be accepted by the scientific
Community as a procedure that is not
intrusive as a procedure you know that
is ideal and does not put the animal at
risk
for two energy cannot carry a pregnancy
to full term one is infertile the other
two walls so a surrogate southern white
rhino will be used this female rhinos
are the candidates of this procedure
they have to be monitored regularly
scientists that we're talking to say it
has been a long journey to get this
right
Zakaria mutai takes care of the
endangered species as well as Black
Rhinos that roam all pajetta he says the
cows are ready for the embryos to be
implanted we want to do is to do it as
natural as possible because for the
surrogate mothers we don't want to give
them the hormonal injection it might
create some problem so we had to do a
vasectomy on a southern white animal to
act as a teachable
so when it started mounting in any of
the females we know this is the best
time of doing the first implantation
rhinos are under thread because poachers
hunt them for their horns the northern
white subspecies was wiped out in South
Sudan Uganda and other parts of central
Africa decades ago conservationists have
spent years on this research and finally
it's bearing fruits Catherine soy Al
Jazeera all pageta Conservancy in
central Kenya